to afghanistan where the u.s wrapped up
its military presence weeks ago only to
see the taliban return to power now
washington has stopped inbound flights
carrying evacuees after discovering that
some new arrivals in the u.s had measles
this comes after the united nations
condemned the taliban's crackdown on
protesters there the office of the high
commissioner for human rights said at
least four people had been killed in
demonstrations the un is now calling on
the taliban to seize the use of force
against demonstrators and journalists
covering the rallies
for more on this let's bring in
journalist franz marty in kabul
afghanistan friends welcome again the un
has condemned the taliban crackdown on
protesters and journalists that's all
well and good but is it likely to have
any impact on taliban leaders
so far
i can't see that it had any impact it's
also given the government they announced
all like their old hard liners
um nothing of like inclusiveness uh it
sent a sign that the taliban are focused
on internal cohesion and less on how
they look to the outside world so if
they think that protests
get like dangerous for them
they
will likely
heavy-handedly uh if necessary try to
like subdue them so so far they haven't
like reversed any of their decision
and uh i think it's unlikely that they
will
the u.s has halted flights from
afghanistan because of what looks like a
measles outbreak what does this mean for
further evacuations
um as far as i can tell these measle
outbreaks this was a flight like from
afghans that were flewn out
some days weeks ago and then were
processed on u.s bases in third
countries germany and qatar for example
and then went from there to the states
so here there has just been two days ago
the first flight with like about 200 uh
foreign passport holders so evacuation
because of the situation at the airport
that was not running have any way been
like on a low scale and the system is
not completely clear so uh i think the
impact of this measles outbreak is
limited for the vacation from
afghanistan has rather
an effect on the onboard transportation
for the thousands of people that are
waiting outside of the country now of
course the big topic today is the
20-year anniversary of the 9 11 attacks
a day that changed so much for people in
afghanistan
how do people there see this day
not as you would expect from the west uh
i was on the streets barely anyone uh
realizes that it is
the the anniversary some people even
don't really realize it if you tell them
the date um everything looks like during
the past days so there is neither like
celebration or or like that they reflect
on this a lot
a few people remembered
one
young man in attacks he told me the
reason that it's not special for them in
his words uh for uh for afghans every
day in the past 20 years has been like
11th of september
explaining that like on every day
a lot of people were killed here in
afghanistan
there are of course also different
reactions uh for example
someone when asked about it
stated conspiracy theories that the
americans staged it to invade when i
tried to say that they didn't really uh
need to do that because there have been
terror attacks conducted by bin laden
before 11 september uh he wouldn't like
acknowledge that uh then someone offered
it it was the israelis so you have also
these conspiracy theories
but in general it's like
many people don't know and the one that
do they don't really care about
friends marty in kabul afghanistan thank
you very much